this morning texas is holding its first
primary election since the legislature
approved a controversial new voting law
the measure called sb1 restricts mail in
voting it prevents county officials from
sending mail and ballot applications to
voters who didn't ask for them it also
sends drive-through and 24-hour voting
omar villafranco is outside a polling
place in houston omar good morning a lot
of people watching this one
good morning texas had some of the
strictest voting laws even before sb1
was passed but now that sb1 is law even
some of the most experienced voters are
having problems getting their ballot
counted
this is my first right of citizenship
i'm they're not going to take that away
from me pam gaskins says she's only
missed one election in over 50 years
for the last i think
six or seven years i've been
voting by mail how was it this time
around
an absolute nightmare the 74 year old is
a member of texas's league of women
voters and she almost missed the mail-in
ballot application deadline after
getting rejected twice due to changes to
state voting laws including a newly
added voter identification requirement
for applications and ballots that says a
voter's id must be the same type of id
that was used when the person registered
to vote which was news to gaskin the
first option is your driver's license
number
the next line says if you do not have a
texas driver's license
put in the last four digits of your
social security number that form does
not say it has to be the one you
registered with you put your driver's
license i put my driver's license on
what did you need to put on i should
have put my social security
lisa wise is the elections administrator
for el paso county she says more mail-in
ballots than ever are being flagged for
rejection due to sb1 we spoke to her on
friday
right now our ballots are at about a 34
percent rejection rate el paso is not
alone 12 percent of mail-in ballots were
flagged for rejection in travis county
home to austin and in harris county the
nation's fourth largest which covers
houston 29 percent of mail-in ballots
were flagged for rejection almost all of
them because of sb1 in my mind sb was a
voter integrity bill state senator paul
bettencourt co-authored sb1 which his
republican colleagues touted as making
it easy to vote and hard to cheat after
talking to also county leaders
they're saying
easier to vote not so sure catch fraud
we're not referring any of these for
indictment or for investigation whenever
there's changes in a system there's
always going to take time for people to
and the election
officials to understand how that works
but gaskins says the new rules are the
latest in a series of obstacles that
deter voters they're making voting hard
period
election officials have spent the past
few weeks contacting voters whose
ballots were rejected by mail by
telephone trying to get them to correct
it now keep in mind this is going to
affect voters in both parties but we
won't know which party had more problems
until after the election
nate
omar thank you